good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight while washington's mass
delusion tour continues it's amazing to
watch just hours ago in the latest
installment the secretary of defense and
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff held a press conference at the
pentagon and they told us what they've
been telling us all week from the white
house and the state department and
everybody in charge they're telling us
that our departure from afghanistan the
one that looks like a disaster to you
has in fact this is directly from lloyd
austin the secretary of defense been a
resounding success
of course if you subtract the 13 dead
americans the two dozen trapped school
children the afghans falling off
airplanes or the fact that we armed the
taliban with 90 billion dollars worth of
automatic weapons and helicopters it's
been great
they're saying this so often however
that it may not be propaganda it is
starting to seem like everyone in the
biden administration actually believes
they just won
and that might explain why they're
promoting jennifer rubin columns from
the washington post and walking away
from reporters without taking any
questions they don't have to explain
themselves it's obvious this is a
victory
watching all this should worry you there
are only two explanations for it either
every senior government official in
washington has been chugging ayahuasca
and has departed from reality on the
early train and that's possible
or
on some deeper level maybe they're
actually telling the truth as they
understand it
when they say this is a victory maybe
from their perspective it is maybe what
looks like chaos is in fact a plan of
sorts and maybe that plan is working
just fine
now how can that be you ask this is all
clearly a disaster it's on television
voters hate it the polls show that very
clearly so by any normal calculation
politically democrats would be very
worried about the next election they're
going to be punished obviously in the
midterms and republicans are all excited
about the whopping they think they will
deliver
and yet democrats seem strangely content
and self-confident
why
well here's one theory unproven of
course just throwing it out there to
think about defense secretary lloyd
austin announced that the biden
administration has evacuated about 125
000 civilians from afghanistan only 6
000 of them lloyd austin told us are
americans the rest are afghans and of
those very few of the afghans were
translators or aids or contractors the
allies were hearing so much about who
fought with the us military and who
deserve our support and may deserve our
support of that group there are only a
few thousand
you can be sure of this from a lot of
different signs but here's one sign the
health department in alexandria virginia
a very liberal town it's taking
thousands of refugees and the health
department there just put out this
urgent request quote
alexandria health department is looking
for pashto-dari speakers to assist with
translation support for recent arrivals
oh
so the one thing we know about these
recent arrivals is they're not
translators because translators probably
wouldn't need translators these are
instead refugees who don't speak english
so the question is where are they going
next
where will these people be living three
years from now
that's a fair question you can tell it's
a highly relevant question because
whenever you ask it the biden
administration servants in the national
news media start to screech about how
you're a racist and need to shut up
immediately
they're getting caught up in what i call
the brown menace which is this uh
trumper right wing fear of people coming
into the country from central and south
america these people seem to be getting
swept up into that xenophobia stephen
miller's response to the collapse of
afghanistan the fall of kabul the
takeover of the taliban was look at
biden he's trying to he's trying to get
brown people to come into the country um
it's it's sickening and it's it's
pathetic
as we told you before the little [ __ ]
on the right did that hit from chill
mark on martha's vineyard and we've been
begging the state department please send
125 000 afghan refugees to chill mark on
martha's vineyard because the people
there are open-minded clearly they are
how many refugees do you think are going
to wind up in chill mark
right around zero but the funniest part
is when those two characters describe
the posh tunes coming to our country as
brown people that's hilarious because
for the record they are not brown
they're likely whiter than you are but
whatever the point is cnn wants you to
know that you don't have a right to know
how many of these people are coming here
from afghanistan and where they're going
what neighborhoods are they going to be
living in
but of course you have a right because
it's your country you own it you pay for
it you were born here it belongs to you
so you have a right to know what happens
in your country we looked into it
because that's what we're paid to do
so if you've gone online recently and
visited the official website of the
state department run by mr tony blinken
you'd have found a list of what they
call welcoming communities these are
places where afghan refugees in
particular special immigration visa
holders will be settling in the united
states
and if you look at that list long enough
you may notice something especially if
you cover politics you may notice that
these communities
include an awful lot of swing districts
and swing states all over the united
states it's not just virginia
three of these communities are in texas
the state the democratic party has tried
to flip for years now it's their first
priority
one of these cities is austin one is
dallas and others houston the state
department has also urged afghans to go
to the state of pennsylvania does
pennsylvania need more people probably
not a lot of unemployment
between pittsburgh and philadelphia but
pennsylvania is also a state that donald
trump won in 2016. so maybe they should
go there
florida atlanta georgia nevada colorado
they're also on the list are you
surprised by this
funny
one swing state that's not on the
official list is wisconsin but they're
getting a lot of refugees from
afghanistan too this hasn't been
publicly announced we learned on monday
when congressman tim tiffany joined us
to describe his visit to fort mccoy in
the state of wisconsin
he said of the 2000 afghan nationals
there none were special immigrant visa
holders meaning none had worked for the
us military none of them were quote
allies the people to whom we owe free
health care
he also said that these afghans despite
not being allies were free to walk off
the base anytime into our country and
just move here like whatever
no paperwork for them nobody was
stopping them
and they're about to be a lot more
people like this at that base cbs news
is now reporting that fort mccoy is
being asked to hold up to 13 000 afghans
the governor of wisconsin aware of this
what do the people of wisconsin think of
it nobody cares what they think it's not
their country
oh but it is and you should be nervous
watching this in a truly democratic
system in a functioning democracy the
people who wrecked afghanistan and
humiliated the united states and sapped
american power maybe forever would be
punished badly in the midterms they
would lose power over this they'd be
held accountable and they know that so
they're doing everything they can to
avoid accountability
to avoid an election they will lose
they're flooding swing districts with
refugees they know
will become loyal democratic party
voters they're opening the southern
border to more than 200 000 illegal
migrants per month
that's the equivalent of nearly two
afghan airlifts every 30 days
and above all they are using covid to
change how we vote
these are the tools they are using to
maintain power and maintaining power
let's be completely clear and never
forget has always been and always will
be their only goal and that's why the
cdc which for generations was a
respected public health authority and
for good reason was created to fight
malaria did a good job at that now seems
to be in charge of housing policy
remember when rochelle walensky defied a
supreme court ruling earlier this year
to tell you that you can't evict people
from your home for any reason even if
they're not paying rent
once he has not been fired for that she
didn't apologize for it for desecrating
our constitution for mocking the supreme
court no
instead the butt administration has
given her more power which she now has
watch as she tells you you probably
shouldn't travel for the holiday weekend
even if you've been vaccinated
we have actually articulated that people
who are fully vaccinated um
and
who are wearing masks can travel um
although given where we are with disease
um transmission right now um we would
say that um people need to take their
own these risks into their own
consideration as they think about
traveling first and foremost if you are
unvaccinated um we would recommend not
traveling
okay so this is a partisan democrat
for whom the concerns of the democratic
party are never far from mine so you
have to think of it through a political
lens because trust us
they do
why are they making you more fearful
than you necessarily need to be some
people should be very afraid of covet
but not everybody should be what is this
about
well maybe it's for the same reason they
would like hundreds of thousands of
afghans to flood into swing states it
gives them the power to change the rules
of our democracy so they don't lose
another election considering what's
happening right now in california's
recall election which is about two weeks
from today
in february the state's legislature in
california passed a law requiring that
all registered voters get a mail-in
ballot even if they didn't ask for a
mail-in ballot why would you do that
well kovitt of course quote the pandemic
has not gone away said one california
assemblyman
now here we are in september and of
course they're telling us the pandemic
has still not gone away and that is
convenient for them
and specifically for gavin newsom who
knows that mail in ballots which by
definition lack any form of voter id
cannot be verified
those kind of ballots overwhelmingly
benefit his party because they abet
voter fraud
in connecticut the democratic party is
now allowing anyone to vote absentee as
long as they say they're afraid of
getting sick quote anyone who's afraid
of contracting covet or expects they'll
be sick one town clerk announced is
entitled to a mail-in ballot
now these orders came directly from the
state's secretary of state who is of
course a partisan democrat the town
clerk told the local media outlet that
the changes to connecticut's voting
system are likely to become permanent no
matter what happens with kofit
so this isn't about public health
this is about elections if it was about
public health they'd be telling you to
lose weight
but they're not
this is about elections
but whatever you do don't notice that
don't ask questions but the thousands of
afghans they haven't vetted
we're quoting now i can absolutely
assure you that no one is coming into
the united states of america who's not
been through a thorough screening and
background check process that's what joe
biden's press secretary said just today
but it's a lie
meanwhile hundreds of thousands of
unidentified illegal aliens stream
across the southern border every month
who are these people we don't know we
can't know
in a functioning democracy
this wouldn't work
voters wouldn't put up with it even
partisan democrats would say come on now
you have to have a border it's a country
so when you start behaving this way so
outside the bounds
of normal behavior so far from what the
population actually wants
clearly you don't
plan to be held accountable at the
election
you plan to change the way the election
works and that's exactly what they're
doing
sorry it's true hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else